All right, so can you use this Bayes net to help work things out?
>> Yeah, actually it make it a lot easier. I
was, I was thinking about how I would do this and,
and wouldn't involve writing a whole lot of equations and doing
a whole lot of stuff but actually, just by writing out
the Bayes net we ended up, and filling out these tables
we ended up doing that. So, the, the bottom table is,
basically tells me the probability of, ball two being some color.
In a world where ball one is known to be green.
Because we just broke down that part of the table, so
we don't have to do it for every other one. And,
you know, if I knew that I were in box one,
then the probability of it being blue in a world where
ball one was green is in fact zero. And if I
knew I were in box two. Then the probability of it
being blue in, where ball one is green, and where box
two is three quarters. So I only care about that last column.
>> All right.
>> And now I just
have to choose the row or choose how to
distribute the likelihood over the row. So all I
really need to know is, what's the probability of
me being in box one and being in box two.
>> All right, which we have in the table as well, as a half.
>> Right. So that means the probability of
it being ball two. Being, ball two being
blue in a world where ball one is green, is just the probability of ball two
being blue, given that ball one is green. And we want to
know the probability two is blue given that one is green
but when you look at the table and all we care
about is that last column, all we really want to know is, well,
we know the answer when box one, when we're in box
one, when box equals one, it's zero, and we know the
answer when box equals two, it's 3 4s. So if we
were going to do a sample, for example, which we talked about earlier,
we would just sample a bunch of times, and we would get
0 sometimes and we would get 3 4s sometimes. And that would
be great, except of course, we want to compute this exactly. And
we know how to compute it exactly, because we actually know the distribution
over, how many times box would be equal to 1 and how
many times box would be equal to 2. It would be half
in each case. So, I really like, I think you've made this
easier by giving us the table. So, actually writing out the Bayes net.
So we want to know the probability that the second ball
is blue given that the first ball is green. And that's
just equal to the probability that the second ball is blue.
Given that the first ball is green and we were in
box one. Because if we knew that, we knew we were
in box one and the first ball we drew was green,
it'd be really easy to compute the probability of the second
ball being blue. It's right there in the table at zero.
>> Is this, is this the
way that you think it should be written?
>> Almost, but not quite. That would be the easy thing to do because we know
that answer. We know the probably that box is equal to 1. It's just a half. But
it's not just the probability that box is
equal to one, it's the probability that box
is equal to one in a world where we knew the first thing we drew was green.
>> Gotcha.
>> And if we had that then it would be easy to figure out the, the products
there to figure out two is blue in a
world where the box one is green. Boxes equal
to 1 and the first ball that we pulled was equal to, was green. And then we will
just add that to the probability that the second
ball we drew was blue. Given that the first
ball that we drew was green. And we were
in box two. We were drawing from box two.
And that would have to be weighted by the prober-, probability that box was
two in a world where the first ball that we grew, drew was green.
>> Good. Very good. And in fact, this
rule that you kind of worked through follows
just algebraically from two of the rules that
we just talked about. It's the combination of
the marginalization rule, which let's us introduce this
box variable. But the way that we wrote
it before, it was, you have to and it in. But then we actually then applied
the chain rule to split that into a conditional probability. So, so this is
all valid at the moment. And are these quantities that we, that we know?
>> Well, we certainly know the very first term in each
of the two summands. Can it be summands? Let's say they're
summands. If they're not, we'll get nasty emails from people. The
first part's probability. Second ball is blue given that the first
one is green in red box one. And
the probablity that the second ball is blue given
that the first one is green in red
box two. That's easy, that's actually in the table.
>> That's easy, that's in the table. And it's
zero in this case, and three quarters in this case.
>> Right, so it's zero in the first case and
it's three quarters in the second case, straight outta the table.
Now all we have to do is figure out how
often we're in box one and how often we're in box
two and if you didn't think it through you would just have
the probability of box equals one and the probability of box equals two.
But we have to remember we're in a world where the first ball
we picked was green. So now we just have to compute each of
those terms. So how do we do that? So we want to
know what the probability is that boxes, we're in box 1 given that
we picked a green ball first. Well that one's actually much easier to
think about because Bayes' rule will give us, will allows us to express
this in quantities where we do know the answer. Because we have the tables. So
that would be the probability that the first ball was green given that we were
in box 1 times the probability
that we're in box 1 divided by the probability that the first thing we picked
is green. So, the probability that we get a green ball if
we pick box one, is just well, it's three quarters.
>> Yep. It's.
>> A different three quarters than the other one though.
>> Yeah. Those, those two three
quarters aren't the same three quarters. This,
this way. Because sometimes, two three quarters
are not the same two three quarters.
>> In this case, there are three green balls and one, what
we're pretending to call yellow because it's easier to write than orange, ball.
And so three of the four of them are green, so if we
were in box one, we close our eyes, we'd get three of those.
So what the probability that we're in box one? Well, it's
right there in the table, to Bayes' net, it's one half. Now
we just have to figure out well, what's the probability that
I would get a green ball the first time I picked one?
>> Right. And so one easy way to do
that is, we actually do this, this whole process again
on box two, and then just normalize. Or we
could break this apart using the, using the marginalization rule.
>> Yeah,
which one do you want to do?
>> The first one I think.
>> Okay. So figuring out the probability the first
one is green isn't, isn't as easy as it
looks. You can't just say, well there are five
green balls, but there's a total of nine balls,
and so it's 5 9th, because those nine balls
aren't distributed equally on both sides of the boxes.
So you really have to, you still have to
know which box that you're in, in some sense.
>> Right.
>> But we can kind of skip that step. Okay,
so I like this, so what's the probability that the first ball
is green given that we're in box two, well it's just 2
5ths. Prove by looking at the screen. And what's the prior probability
that we're in box two? Well, it's just a half because that
was given to us on the table. And so, we still don't
know the prior probability of, of the first ball being green, but
it turns out we don't have to because there are only two
boxes and so we can just normalize and the right thing will happen.
So, three quarters times one half is equal to three eighths. And 2/5 times
1/2 is equal to 2/10 or 1/5. And
that's right. So 3/8 is also 15 over 40. 1/5 is 8 over 40. Why do
we do that? Because we want to be able
to add them up and normalize and so that means
if you added those two together and put them
in the denominator, that would give you 23 over 40.
And, so how much is 15 40ths of 23 over 40ths well, it's 15 out of 23.
And so, without ever directly computing the probability that
1 equals green. We know that the probability of
us being in box 1, given that the first
ball pulled was green is 15 over 23. Which
was a lot of work to do considering that
we knew we were going to multiply it by zero.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Which meant none of this work mattered.
>> Okay.
>> Or we did it because we love probability.
>> No it was, it was kind of helpful because
we needed to know how to normalize these two numbers.
>> Right, so it was useful but, I
mean, just the whole thing we already kind of knew.
>> Yeah.
>> That [LAUGH] that was going to be zero.
>> But this one we didn't know.
>> Right, this one we didn't know, and so now we know that the, the
other case is 8 23rds, and we're done. So 0 times 15, divided by 23 is
0, and three quarters times 8 23rds is 24 over 92.
>> Right, and we can, there's a factor of
4 in both of those. So it's actually 6 23rds.
>> That's what I said.
>> Woohoo!
>> Wow.
>> [LAUGH]
Boy it would be nice if we had an algorithm to do this for us.
>> Man, and the algorithm shou, shou, should not involve me. [LAUGH]